[Music]
this will be an historic election for
many reasons in congress it could be
another record-breaking year
with more women of color running for the
house of representatives than
ever before of the 318 women on the
ballot for the senate
and the house 117 about 36 percent
are women of color nicole killian went
on the campaign trail to talk with some
of them
pat timmons-goodson is back on the trail
thank you for coming i enjoyed it how
did it feel
it felt like home we caught up with the
congressional candidate as she resumed
in-person campaigning at this drive-in
church service
y'all let's pray with our feet and go
out here
and vote her latest stop crisscrossing
north carolina's eighth district
one of the most competitive in the
country what do you see
as the key issues in this race right now
health care health care health care she
got into the race after serving as the
first black woman
on the state supreme court hoping to
make history again
you are one of a record number of women
of color
running what does that mean to you i'm
proud
i am excited i'm
hopeful i'm prayerful at this time
in our nation's history women
of color are offering themselves
a record 117 women of color are nominees
for the house and senate this cycle
84 democrats and 33 republicans
approximately half are african-american
and more than a quarter hispanic
i am running for congress because many
people in our representative offices
aren't representing us candace
valenzuela would be the first
afro latina in the house of
representatives if she flips her texas
seat this is a very powerful
thing for me but it's also very
disappointing
we've had so many firsts over the last
couple of years that that should have
been first a long time ago
i will be the first korean-american
republican to serve in the united states
congress
young kim is in a rematch in southern
california where immigration has been a
focal point of her campaign i'm an
immigrant
and i'm a mother of four and i'm a small
business woman
i want my story to be an inspiration
for the next generation and for a
congress quickly becoming
more diverse looking at the possibility
that we're going to increase that
diversity
makes me even more optimistic and
hopeful for
for this country the current congress
is the most racially and ethnically
diverse in history but much of that is
in the house
over in the senate only five women of
color have
ever served in that chamber including
senator kamala harris so if she and the
former vice president win next week
it would certainly be historic but also
mean a potential loss for her seat here
on the hill
right now there are only two women of
color who are
nominees for the senate this cycle
anthony nicole thank you
very exciting what's happening no when
you look at the numbers it's hard to
believe that it's taken this long but
i'm just glad that we are finally here
yeah glad that we're finally here it's
nice that congress can look like the
country
yeah yeah it's it's been it's overdue
but it's finally starting to change it's
catching up i like what she said tony
when she said you know there have been
so many firsts
these last two or three years yeah it's
just been a cycle
this is i think a continuation of the
way we saw four years ago with
you know with all those with so many
women exactly running and then ending up
in congress